vous croyez votre monde en sécurité
c'est une illusion savourer ses derniers
moments de paix
vous savez tous ce qui s'est passé à
londres l'homme qui a fait ça est l'un
de nos meilleurs agents au supérieur ont
commis un crime que je ne peux pardonner
aucun de vous n'êtes à la bouillie
et j'ai toute votre attention maintenant
c'est peut-être le commencement autorisé
moelle poursuivre mais vendetta n'a pas
sa place dans sa rigueur
c'est peut-être un port monsieur
tu as quand même pas courir après steve
non ce qu'il faut que je fasse ou pas
j'en sais rien je sais seulement ce que
je peux faire
c'est maintenant ou jamais
on ne passera pas on m'a passé
qu'on passerait je ne suis pas sûr que
le mot qu'on vienne
je vous ai vu assassiné des innocents
sauf qu'ils seraient à répondre de vos
actes
vous n'avez pas idée des conséquences
des vôtres
je marcherai sur vos corps brisés
on est moins certain
on frappe directe je suis meilleur
moi quoi en tout